this week we are partnered with hellofresh
and Rocket money more on them after the
reaction well hello there citizens of the
reject Nation I'm fresh out of the shower
still got a little bit of drizzle on my hair so
I'm feeling extra Suave today Andrew Gordon how
are you buddy I'm doing good but I'm not in
this movie and it's a guy Richie film and I
don't understand see Let Me Explain we covered
guy Richie's Wrath of Manar in Jason the thumb
and we loved it yes we did and so we wanted to
continue with some guy Richie films as promis
so we're going to continue with the man from
Uncle is a movie I've been wanting to see for
a very long time I honestly don't know why I
put it off for so long I've heard that Henry
cavell's really fun in this movie so I figured
yeah man let's keep this train going all righty
well you know what to do leave a like leave in
the comments other guy Richie films you really
recommend I forgot to mention I have seen the
two Sherlock Holmes movies right and I forgot
he did those be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell to get notified when
our reaction is up for something that might
pique your interest thank you to prepper for
helping to set down these highlights and thank
you to all who have follow us at our patreon
becoming super sexy rejects that's where you
get the full length Reaction watch along where
you sync up with your own copy of The Man
from Uncle and we cover several things over
there exclusively with highlights and watch
along included Andrew you ready let's do it
this is giving me Oceans 11 Vibes I was about
to say that but I let you do it World War II
ends Germany split between East and West I think
this is based on a television show I believe so
y oh yes right cannibal
hamers in [Music] this 196 63
okay damn look at this production yeah
holy crap this sets wow this feels
like Superman more Aesthetics so good
that's Suave Suave should have worn my
suit I like how he's using like
zoom lenses that are like a 60s
movie like the actual film
aesthetic looks like a 60s
film
hey great angle from down look it up who are you
and what do you want I'm here to have a friendly
chat about your father I don't have a father I I
don't have a father I mean your real father Dr Udo
teller Hitler's favorite rocket scientist I've
always wanted to meet Hitler's favorite rocket
scientist two years ago he disappeared like Steam
from a tea kettle like Steam from a tea kettle say
come
on oh my God The Details Matter until now this
was taken last week in row which one is supposed
to be my father but if your father's knowledge
gets into the wrong hands things could get a
little messy you know end of the world like that
classical American Voice he's doing what makes
you think I know where he is I don't think you
do but I think you know someone who does your
mother's brother Uncle Rudy I've also been told
that your father was never Act a Nazi actually
a Nazi I'm here to help it why don't you help
me with what if I had 15 minutes we' drink tea
eat biscuits I talk you laugh and we be on our
way unfortunately I don't so my offer uh oh he's
the Cal's coming Che little hotel in West Berlin
in less than an hour Canal Hammer stay here and
spend the night with the Russians hanging from
a pipe having your toils removed that is what
I was looking for this performance feels more
like a TR additional Clark can Superman than
actual than the one we got from him I love him as
Superman I do but this feels like the traditional
portrayal in a lot of ways like he's doing a
great job embodying the era like it's a little
hiding but it's still believable are they still
following us yes yeah he's charming and swab yeah
I like how much fun he's actually having used
to seeing him play like real serious brooding
characters is there one of them hum if there is
is he looking at us he wants to eat [Music] her
wow a great D Dutch angle that's cool when
you hear something that sounds like a gunshot
drive this is suspenseful oh oh whoa whoa that
early you know a gunshots coming but somehow
that still got you let's just hope he doesn't
drive as quickly as he [Music] moves must not
be used to silencers this was still pretty loud
wow wow wow oh this is a blast already take a
right and then an immediate left he has to
read like an actual physical [Music] map oh
great stunt work holy [__] wow
damn amazing oh with these like
classic vehicles too hold [Applause]
[Music] on smooth hell of a parallel
Parker yeah I need a rear view camera now to
parallel park right is he gone I don't think
so almost feels like the Terminator
the way he's like using his vision
reference Andrew reference number
one just number one and uh made me
back [Music] here little tiny
good little tiny good for Army
Hammer wow he is so good at
getting you to follow a in a
way that is very unique and specific to KY [Music]
Richie I loving the way this is shot whoa
[Applause] whoa wow and this moment then
the James Bond music comes on that emulates
the darkness oo great reflection of the light
thereo Napoleon solo what a fascinating
name how skinny he looks
there badass and
intelligent like a spy and a
criminal love how they kept that Frozen in the
play what a fascinating way to
keep subtitles feel like [Music]
action finally that's such a Trope in
movies they never go for the [Music] tires
oh his run reminds me of the liquid
Terminator reference actually is pretty
similar and he's grabbing the back of the car
he's trying to stop the car oh my God God he's a
jackhammer oh we're struggling here why don't you
take a shot at him somehow it just
doesn't seem like the right thing to
do whoa made you wait just long enough to
wonder if it was actually going to fall in
a FR this road isn't going anywhere taking
us exactly where we want to go it's all
part of the plan it's all part of the plan
refence red soone boom is that c it looks
like a combination all we have to do is get
over two 20t WS in a mfi now what oh my God
that's so erotic take another left through
the window after you it was all part of the
plan damn oh hey oh my God the wrath
of hammer please don't eat me follow
me the music in this is
exquisite like I like how it feels like classic
the AAS dance music mixed with the Spy fuel when
there is a bit of a cat and mouse dance to them
what are we doing here we're looking for agent
Jones Dr
Jones [Laughter]
whoa
sick this guy is Relentless
oh [Music] awesome erotic step
back you know Henry Cav would be an amazing Bond
because he's having a lot of fun with the role
but he's also got the darkness so he could be
like a combination of a bunch of the arrows
of the bonds It's a combination of connory and
Craig play is in chic it isn't even a hotel he's
wearing an apron and economic system on others is
the primary cause of World tension today this is
the year he was assassinated 63 I trust that Miss
taler was help the uncle off V trou is the best
Shan Uncle that's jur I didn't ask you to line up
half of East Berlin they were waiting for me don't
flatter yourself they follow everybody what was
waiting for me was barely human you should have
seen it run call it it like a Terminator we
are not in the habashy business I don't think
you understand it tore the back off my car it it
how long was your prison sentence we can make it
longer you owe me five more years like the Devil
he's part of the suicide squad I don't ever make
the calamitous error of mistaking my deliberate
shortsightedness for blindness I'd love the voices
these Brits are doing I sort of get the Vibe
of like cuz guy Richie is British of him this
is like an homage to the American films he kind
of grew up watching like the action spy Capers
could be way off I tell myself solo that inside
every crowd there's an American trying to get
out anything in particular sir or are you just
looking what I'm about to feed
you solo might taste a little
better where are we going with this
uh they're going to have to work
together oh my God Henry cavl in a
bathroom fight I love it I understood that
reference he just letting them work it
out dude come on Henry do the they are
fighting like the Terminators actually yeah
[Music] hey my best your best you be I need
subtitles I think that means let him go just
guessing or eat him what does that mean he
said don't kill your partner on your first
day Miss tell's Uncle Rudy is a senior executive
the founder Sergio vinera was a friend of molini
and a known fascist his son Alexander and
his wife Victoria who is this actor looks
very familiar all our information indicates ah
ah Elizabeth dicki Aisha from Guardians of the
Galaxy imagine the consequences if he builds an
atom bomb for them that would be bad your mission
should you choose accept it and to retrieve
Dr Taylor and his research it will be located
in a computer disc and whoever has that disc
will simply be the most powerful nation in the
world W this is like Mission Impossible yeah our
Russian friend will focus on Miss teller and her
uncle Rudy who's going to get the disc and who's
going to be okay with the other one getting the
disc oh wow this is all just a big RSE I love
that or they all just SP finish at the exact
same time you understand humiliation better
than most after your performance last night
I thought I should read up on you I love his
delivery your dad being a big palet stalins
and a top government official with all the
perks and privileges right up until he was
caught embezzling party fun jesz were you when
he was sent at the gag 10 11 years old love this
one upmanship was that when the psychotic episode
started he's pay attention to every little tick I
do wonder if it was your father's shame that
gave you such drive though psychologically
profiling him clever he knows how to get
to his core I love this Crescendo of the
music he has got a really bad temper problem
but I love that the like in the Spy Thriller
we're getting like a buddy cop type of film
now it's interesting how Henry caval doesn't
really view him like human he treats
him so much more less than that yeah
and it pains me that the genre of the
because of the genre production designs
like this don't get recognized in like
Oscar season and stuff cuz this is Dro
de gorgeous it's beautiful this should
tell you how important this mission is to
everyone I'm not going back behind that
wall you're the star of the show my woman
would never wear anything like that why
did he call me his woman because I am now
your fiance this is not part of the cover he's
just claiming her no no no no no no no smoothly
done the stature and build of both Henry
caval and Arvy h on the safe screen an
interesting contrast he's also managed to
secure a Visa for his fiance and naturally
you'd introduce him to your beloved Uncle Rudy
you just got to play along with it what's your
cover Jack devil Antiquity Ste specializing
in Greek and Roman sculpture okay gets the
most sophisticated of them all Soviet architect
traveling to Rome would never dress his woman
in the clothes you try to put her in you try
to dress her like someone on your side think
someone dressed behind the Iron Curtain she's
from behind the Iron Curtain Army Hammer being
controlling of a women not likely you can
get back on your horse now Cowboy I'll see
you in Rome what about the Americans playing
the Russian and the British guys playing the
American but it's missing a little something now
we are engaged congratulations he thinks he's so
sve it's fascinating to see like Army Hammer play
the stronger type stronger character compared to
Henry caval you know like Henry caval is
strong and everything uh very skilled but
it's very clear that between like he's like
Army Hammer the the Jackhammer of the two of
them it's really interesting he's not he's
not the main muscle of them but he's still a
muscle but yeah for sure I have a quick errand
to run could you have my bag taken to my room
please of course thank you dude they are really
nailing the look down oh damn she was eyeing
him I mean he's Henry C the same place every
architect goes when they visit the own sure that
happens everywhere he goes oh my God this is the
staircase in every action movie bombs happen and
stuff and these steps were constructed
in 1723 he making the [__] up credited
to to Italian Architects really built by
Russian Ser ianov sedge also had mother
who introduced him to classical architecture
and whom he revered [Music] as in memory of
his beloved Yaga he make one step to
celebrate every year so she died at
135 so she gave birth at the age of 65 evening
comrade you're not supposed to be making contact
in public being followed they divert when you turn
down the steps and they'll be waiting ahead for
you I will handle them I destroy them someone is
trying to make sure that your fiance is really an
architect not someone who's trained how to fight
KGB agent for example you are not needed here
oh yeah you've got to play the yeah I think you
should do as he says and remember take it like a
[Music] [__] i' never saw the
show Henry caval was all this is
usually the most fun I've seen him have
nice shoes thank you perhaps you give
them to me okay give me some money for
coffee give the gentleman something for
coffee oh Western
standoff nice watch wow oh did his father
or mother give him that watch give him
the watch and the ring oh damn these are
all personal items don't just give it up
thank you yeah without hesitation he you look
like you're just voluntarily doing it give me
the one the [Music] oh it's great set up
for the coffee scene to this or the table
soon no what are you doing man know what
are you doing man calm down not very good
at this whole subtly thing either you start
to look like you know what you're doing or
I'm out of here I will say cannibal Hammer
definitely brings a the hurt boy inside of
those eyes to this performance with the
compliments of the hotel I apologize it
wasn't brought up earlier thank you very much
is there anything else I can do for you oh God
it's a fine bottle of champagne don't want to
be alone ashamed to drink it alone yes it would
be oh subtle I'm still on duty Mr Deany so you got
sick my shift ends in 5 minutes sure
we can find something to do for five
minutes so Charming couldn't tell if she was like
uncomfortable or what I was a little confused
on the way she was handling it would you like
bigger glass I will finish this bottle are you
going to help me or not no thank you disciplined
Russian not in the v i could see like the arcs of
of certain things they have to overcome these
two seems like Henry cavali just going to be a
constant I like how she's kept slightly
out of [Laughter] focus this is not a
good idea styles are just such in contrast
no fan dancing by yourself I need a partner
no as you can dance is there supposed to be
like a romance form in between these [Music]
two guess they're building towards
it and then oh it's like how many
more times do I got to be slapped
tonight now play his rageb building
music you're not an East German Chop Shop anymore
still no drink don't you make me put you over
my knee what wow so you don't want to dance but
you do want to wrestle I cannot say that what is
damn throw about him fall
asleep Lua mender did that's surprisingly
realistic on that what if it's all part of
her plan to make him calm down so is
better than character this time I do
need to go that is disappointing
just another 5 minutes a long 5
minutes his hair is perfect that's how
all our hair looks after uh 5 minutes
and what are you doing you're
not supposed to be here these are
Russian made
these perfect and very L Tech puts them down
my bow tie doesn't work with that suit it's
better for the mission that we get to know
each other a little bit more intimately
what does that mean it means I like my woman
strong strong going on date we're going to
box bump the brakes we might be engaged
but I'm I own woman besides I wouldn't
be wearing my engagement ring it's only
just been stolen your fiance would have
gone out first thing in the morning
to replace it wow I nothing like this
person oh there he is [Music]
you such Lush colors everything is so incredibly
vibrant in this it actually feels lived in
[Music] she's eyeing him I gotta say even though
obviously the emotional side supposed to be with
Army Hammer and Alicia viander the movie
is just way more entertaining whenever it
is with enry Cav's character could you please
come with me sir I'm sure we can clear this
up quy y oh I wonder what they do
to people without invitations I'm
Victoria vua I do B of an apologies in
order I'll take it from here thank you
oh she wanted to help him I think
every woman there wants to help
him I'm okay I think did he just put something
on her pretty sure he did you I always thought
Henry Cav was really tall but he's surrounded
by a taller people than him in this film my
favorite niece uncle Rudy Gabby you are a
miracle worker sir I want to hear all about
how you manag to get her out well I ripped the
back off a trunk and we went from there tell
me how does a Russian architect meet a German
car mechanic in East Berlin well it started
when I was brought out to make improvements
on 9 kmers of the wall and one morning I
was coming home he rear ended a tank I met the
most expensive mechanic in East G and did they
make you build the ball as well as design
it ouch you're shaped like a power lifter
[Music] I like the joke yes that's how
he gets buff many is Jing jogging yes
allow me definitely how you build uh oh
apparently Henry Cav couldn't pull it
off they had to cut away call me
St this well I doubt you'll miss
it trust him isn't
it when did this happy accident occur 2 years
ago I wanted to make sure it was serious where
perhaps ashamed why would she be ashamed Rage
music but a good German girl knows never to mix
the blood of a race horse but that of a cart
Force oh that's a fair it's not a fair point
okay that's not a very nice thing to say don't
be so protected sure a waight can himself he's
a jogger but I love how they're zoning out
the sound with like when he's in Rage mode
you're a thief like to call myself a specialist
in complicated Acquisitions that's a fancy way of
saying Thief what is it exactly that you think you
can do for me Mr J an important collection those
one or two special pieces that are impossible
to acquire without the the requisite skill set
Tony Stark always on the tip of my tongue
when I'm about to say something you say
it
the hell Uncle [Music] Rudy he's got to take
his rage out somehow yeah I need to use the
sink so use the ladies take it out bathroom
flight nice to see you wly runs the shipping
department at British oil excuse me I said
I need to use this there I love these Cuts
back and forth Jack Deon yes yes I think we
bumped into each other outside oh that's what
he got the invitation I do apologize not
all I noticed you're very good with your
hands oh excuse me he said use the ladies I
witnessed your trick with a table Club oh my
God they showed it want take I love the subtle
Jabs why how would you mess with this guy he's
huge just remember if you're not first you're
last have the Jets been cleansed and totally
rechecked for sis and flop you want to fix it
oh show up God the mechanic in her show them
up a I love this everyone's got particular
skill sets they're all just groing in that's
NE we don't even need to see what he did to
them I love it you see each one of us is a
destiny and I believe I can help you with yours
wow he just totally switched the tune I can see
us have lunch tomorrow I'm engaged Dar time to go
sorry darling I'll be a minute I'm flirting with
this man being spending a lot of time in bathrooms
recently apparently you put someone called count
Lippy in hospital he had soft bones he had soft
bones how did you find Alexander migua I think
he's an athletic good-looking gazillionaire who
suffered me a j off and made advances towards me
yeah he might as well take it is he trying to
steal me away from my fiance the answer is yes
it's not happening I don't know what you're
upset about you're not even my fiance don't
remind me look at this this film I'm using has
been treated to be sensitive to gamma radiation
gamma blur lines here means they've been in
close proximity to radioactive material in
last 24 hours which means they've succeeded in
enriching the uranium I'm want to go sleep on
this I did think the movie's strengths are at
its best whatever it's like Henry caval Army
Hammer in the same room best when all three are
in the same room together and sometimes I feel
like the movie kind of steers away from that
direction a little too much when I'm like oh
no it's it it's at its strongest when they're all
together yeah they have really good chemistry the
three of them or just when it's on Henry Cavell
honestly I think he's the best part of the movie
oh by far it's not some Henry Cavell Kiss Ass
video he is the best part of the movie I think
this movie is about to give me exactly what I
want wanted is this what you call sleeping on
it I suppose you're responsible for the lights
you're welcome you have to work together we are
different but we are the same I work better
alone I work better alone too I'm not leaving
we have approximately 10 minutes before the power
comes back on you s around and talk about it okay
I'll let you tag a along but it's in and out no
mess so nobody knows we been here and we both
forget about in the morning super Harden Boron
sharpened with a CO2 laser h oh he got a laser
oh goodness oh my God the Russian Tech is so
much better seal to laser just the laser itself
love how everything's always a competition
with them and you know there is like the
spy gadgets but they don't there's not a heavy
Reliance on them I noticed is there anything I
can do to help you be quiet just let me do it
he's the thief he'd have a better job [Music]
[Laughter] even when he's not delivering lines so
good that was a close one I
love him in this movie love
him no
awesome this looks cool but it's
also kind of conf using a follow at
times this [Music] watch I love the bombastic
operatic like rage it's like that tropea to
Kill Bill whenever they cut to him just
so dramatic when they play [Music] it
oh oh I I felt that he just left standing oh what
exactly did you do to him KGB we call it the kiss
it takes years to master although he's standing
upright he's completely unconscious he'll be like
this for 20 minutes can't touch 10 minutes are
up why do you think they have radiation tools
and suit in a satellite Factory for the atom bomb
next to Hidden buttom we wouldn't have found that
without my father's watch Fair Point your rage
helped what have a go be my guest hold this no
one knows M like he is one of the M I think like
Edgar Wright guy Richie they're excellent at
knowing the music for their films stronger than
most directors it has dual combination locks
triple return rotators and synchronized cylinders
so it's easy to open the earlier model had a
design flaw I intend to exploit very difficult to
open but it's not impossible wow great transition
in there impossible mission impossible people
who designed this model are not very good mhm
at stealing things they should have had a thief
created I however am that's such a great shot oh
I love that a reveal that it's mounted on the door
did you deactivate along model 710 doesn't have an
alarm loving your work Cowboy uh gy Richard really
knows how to make the camera feel like a [Music]
character action sequence God you guys should
warn masks you should have warn masks the
Freeze Frame there cool like a photography
shot does this mean anything to you it's
SP of centrifuge for refining uranium I am not
staying here where are you going to go swimming
[Music] wow [Music] great comedic effect of
knowing that the sound design of what
to keep in frame and what keep out of
frame come on I got three exit
and two of them are close I would
recommend turning before you hit
that wall the last thing I need is
your help they going to jump the wall
they're really riding in that speed
boat oh my oh my God oh my God no
what have you done he told him to shut
up he doesn't even realize he's off the boat
fantastic editing the timing of that was [Music]
perfect I really feel like when I'm
vibing with this movie I'm really
vibing with this movie at times
there's like certain pacing that
can be a bit off but sequences
like this are just so perfectly
executed share it with the
concierge at the hotel sit back and
enjoy you got a little the Superman [Laughter]
curler
just got joy a whole meal whose truck
is there's just a just a whole meal
here got picnic dinner for two they're supposed to
have oh my
god oh is he caring he's
caring going and get him oh
whoa nice to get a moment where it's just all
visuals is he going to get out he knows what he's
do smart this allows him to see that is so
smart saved him the cowboy saved me [Music]
she's going to his
room it's the Nazi race car
driver
uhoh oh it's Uncle
Rudy he knows he knows he knows
things he didn't get places cuz he was
dumb they got a ferris sper this got to get in
there come on guys and he's going to have to
take off his clothes quick sorry Mrs V there's
no answer key key what's going on where's my
case dropped his accent there
hello Victoria uh come on in
[Laughter]
grape she's enjoying Those Grapes sure Victoria
believed you I gave it everything I had I also
got another meeting with her so what we just
let Gabby go with Uncle rudby if there's a
chance he'll lead us to fun do we have a
choice this could be like leading a lamp
to slauter going soft Peril oh yeah your tracker
is not sending a signal you turn it on I think
so or do you want to check it be my guest it's
it's your threer you're the expert I'll be on
the balcony your fiance you're trembling that's
because I'm scared it's going to be okay how do
you know I'll be close by I'll turn on now
yes they yes they are he is so good good at
this fascinating audio choices
here oh I wonder who did
that he really likes to make the camera feel
like like he lets the audience feel like a
character it's it's really interesting I
no that we know wrath man he definitely
does that here like the fact that they you
don't get the audio till the window's down
really interesting choice I know my father is
here and that he works for you and how's that
simple think I've ever seen someone peel a grape
like that I think I need to make a telephone call
but perhaps you come to us at a for Tous time Miss
teller your father's word cathic has been as of
late somewhat lacking your presence will provide
the necessary motivation oh man that's not cool
even off Madame vua will be with
you shortly she would like it if
you make yourself comfortable
every woman wants to bang him
help yourself to a drink that's way
he carries himself too what's in that
drink oh no you don't look like you slept much
last night Mr devony F you should say that Madame
bigua don't think this Scotch is helping either
oh he knows I would say you put something in my
drink called it much easier to trust a drink
you fixed yourself but how did you know I was
going to drink the scotch I didn't I laced all
the drinks smart man I don't like to leave much
to chance I thought I was doing so well well
don't be so hard on yourself you were doing
fantastically well oh he's getting dizzy you
couldn't control the Loyalty of young Gabby I
know my father is here and that he works for you
and how's that my fiance is a KGB agent am wife
has been entertaining with the CIA the Russians
and the Americans thought they were using me but
I was using them to get to you damn it they've
been played it's a tracking device he's probably
out there in the woods watching us right now
it's re he's just so annoyed he's like I've
been here before and last time I fell rather
badly and hurt my head I'm afraid that isn't
going to stop you getting hurt sleep well
whoa hello again Mr SU who turned the power
off we have contact so sorry I can't stay to
finish you off myself go she says the most
sexual things I'll send you a cards to Little
Gabby is this part of their plan Little Gabby
totally betrayed the hell out of them don't
see how it would be unless Henry Cal was in
on it too wouldn't be surprising if it's
part of the plan but we shall see Cally
Army Hammer wasn't on in on it unless he's
just like I'm going to just pretend to act
annoyed for whose who sake for the audience
sake once upon a time there was a little boy
you wouldn't describe him as particularly
special little boy he was neither tall nor
handsome charismatic or amusings like a Bor boy
he was bulu mercilessly and relentlessly by the
other children makes sense he's boring what the
other boys didn't understand about their victim
was that he didn't see them as enemies subjects
man has only two masters in this world and then
names are pain and fear I say love and fear he
had quite a talent for eliciting these feelings
in others so on the principle of playing
to his strengths he decided to make their
cultivation his life's work what a fun way
of showing the backstory history gave him a
World [Music] War oh colorized footage of it it's
like stock footage yeah I think it's Su they take
historical footage and then color it in you will
go here Mr solo a whole page Just For You Solo
page it's okay Henry caval and Payne are good
friends he is not exceedingly dull that's for sure
God they just nailed the look I really feel like
I'm in the 60s when I look at this yeah a shot
like this looks like it looks like film I mean
I'm sure they shot digitally but they convert it
to look like film in a lot of these shots I must
admit does get frustrating but fortunately I'm on
an oldfashioned I think we'll start with the plers
oh and he pissed him off the their first time they
met each other do you mind you don't have to
do things for me to make me talk I'll tell you
everything you won't be able to stop me what about
the Gabby she betrayed you I will testify this guy
just do you still have teller yes has he succeeded
in enriching the urine we are way beyond that
there's already a war a nuclear warri information
torture they're sending a submarine between that
time and now it is being held on vinara island
he just knows oh you can dish it but he can't
take it uhoh it's your call you're the one he's
been having fun with uh too late one hand we need
it I love this out of focus in the background so
what do you think we should do do you smell that
he fixed the glitch left my jacket in
there think this whole reaction I've
just been saying I love Henry Cav in this
movie's he's by far the best part he's so
good and him an Army Hammer do have really
good chemistry man Dad I'll let you two get
reacquainted fem fatel it's tragedy it's
all part of their plan it's tragic there's
irony to it though at the same time come out
there's a lot of slapping in this movie solo
meet again hey he was an Insider we must
give them an appropriate welcome he will
report to Commander wavy of British Naval
intelligence for the of the mission got
it now it is vital you retrieve Dr Teller
and the computer Des but who's going to
get the computer disc kill the Russian if
necessary oo yeah oh exactly I knew that
was going to H I mean it's obvious they know
they're being told the same thing yeah ex of
course but they actually give a [__] about
each other now so there is also of course the
uh small matter of retrieving my agent well
she's not British oh Gabby's working for you
isn't she uh well well done so yeah oh
the most he got there in the end that's
what she was just waiting in the mechanic shop
the whole time I don't understand he's ready
out to resume his work a daugh is touch
Gabby has agreed to assist me to assure
a finish in time you're right she is really
tall she is scary actually I did not notice
when Professor teller disappeared we assumed
that his Nazi colleagues would come knocking
at his daughter's door so we recruited her
okay that makes sense I saw her betrayus at
vinera yes I told it the meeting is confirmed
uh oh yes okay that was well yeah I think it's
rather nice I mean we're obviously all very fond
of Gabby and now we have a chance to to save
her so what is that there it's known as a coupler
it sends a signal which enables another missile
to lock onto this one for double the impact
you need to do something to mess it up to
nuclear come on Gabby I'm sorry we're nearly
done Victoria those are the words we've been
waiting to hear what are you doing let's
both stop playing games shall we put her
in a Cell kill her she is intimidating oh very
much so a computer disc with your research on
it where is it and the backup o like no matter
what whatever agency has that like it's a bad
thing what about Gabby she'll be joining you
shortly no no way they killed the dad a poor
poor Gabby cool oh damn get the wi of that and
the POV of the scope that was a really unique
shot it's like the James Bond credits were
it was an action scene with the the red yeah
yeah wa this is wild holy [__] damn
this is like a gnarly ass at oh my God
wow knows when to break the sound man sound
barrier closing and makes your
eye like pay attention focus
up H the bomb was here and the
discs mother's watch that's I like that
they make the music sound like gunshots
too on that moment when they Cuts
away Alexander has the bomb they're
at the entrance fortunately the bomb
is sabotaged but they still have those
discs oh my
goodness this this is
intense a it's drenched in the
mud
ah holy [__] no one were to lock
off the camera lets moments like
this these feel like make the stunts
feel bigger than usual man Henry Cav
was really behind that wheel woo
that is awesome oh my God that was
great this is a crescendo of a Chase sequence
man h
oh oh gosh oh crap oh right oh I hope
she's okay really love they they know
when it gets those mounted shots from within
that make it feel just so much more real oh
[Music] crap he threw a motorcycle at him that's
awesome you hit on my
fiance that was a great reveal
shot perfectly placed right next to him
yeah just one small snag wrong Warhead
ah she got away so it's a decoy no no no
it's a real bomb quite a nasty one too but
uh not nuclearized there's no uranium in
it there was a second Warhead in the lab
that information would have been helpful
don't even know which boat we're looking
for he died 5 years ago having built Vena
into one of the biggest shipping companies
in the world every detail counts de can you get
them on the radio if we keep them broadcasting
for long enough I have an idea which might
make things quicker what was her [Music]
idea put Henry caval on it Deo this is Napoleon
solo I suspect that you're already listening so
I'll give you this message directly earlier
today I killed your husband he died honorably
courageously and selflessly but he didn't
psychological work it was a rather pitiful
Affair involving tears begging and office to
trade anything and indeed anyone so that I
would SP life yep you get under someone's skin any
blood relation of yours still living will be dead
within a year there's nothing you'll be able to
do but witness their suffering as you await your
own death this I vow on my husband's Soul you
were not faithful to your husband we have the
professor's disc we can build as many bombs as
we need I see one flaw in that plan we've been
locking onto your radio signal now we have your
general location the coupling device that you
so considerately left us on your decoy Warhead
is accurate to 10 ft I have an idea [Music] oh
that Warhead although not nuclear shouldn't have
any trouble obliterating a medium siiz fishing
boat yeah the aforementioned Warhead launched
ready yes proceed please Captain 45 seconds
ago what a fun way to play with time giving
you about 30 seconds until impact it won't
trigger the nuclear warhead as that requires
fishing they're all listening I suggest you
abandon ship immediately oh [__] how's that
for entertainment ah W what a reveal God this
movie is so good it feels like that that was
really good mislead because I wasn't exactly
sure what hug Grant was talking about but I
didn't even question that there was something
more of us I'm not going back to East Germany no
that is probably not a good idea for a British
spy sorry I deceived you I'm sorry I really
wanted to tell you but it's okay I would have
done exactly the same thing in your position we
understand each other let's kiss in case we don't
see each other again kiss you should keep it a
souvenir that way I can keep track of you eat
her Miss impeccable timing every time
they're about to kiss he looks so
annoyed
yeah I knew that was going
to become an issue at the
beginning his identity in this regard
that's where his rage stems from he's
his own man though damn even
without the sound you feel it
I really feel bad for the hotel staff
throughout the whole film here he's just
in Conflict doesn't want to kill him yeah
they formed a nice little partnership here
and they care for each other come in just
finishing up I have your father's watch
let's be friends politics being what they are
can't hide his tions you just cannot play this
yeah mission accomplished head back to Russia
suay like this almost forgot got something for
you my man I didn't see that coming
you know what my mission is same as
mine was doesn't want to kill him screw our
agencies it's form our own agency kill me if
necessary to get that let's just leave it
in the hotel room yeah are they burning it
yeah oh okay that works too it's it's better
that way honestly but I've um spoken to your
superiors and now that we're all such
good friends they've kindly agreed to
let me keep the team together for a while we
leave in an hour where are we going Istanbul
kaken oh and you have a new code name uncle
uncle so the agencies were just cool with all
this don't ah fantastic we
need the sequel the men from
Uncle I'm trying to see if there's any details
here man Why didn't it get a sequel that really
bums me out I I got to assume box office but I
feel like it's become so much more popular over
time and I think Army Hammer's career is thriving
and they should definitely bring him back for
a sequel I mean it would definitely be hard
to do the sequel without him but yeah I I hear
you there a part like he's he's fortunately if
they ever got a sequel he is really good say you
need to bring him back I don't even know the full
story about the Army Hamer thing I just know the
jokes yeah true that are not so funny if they are
true he eats women right sure
and he just got away with
it all right well let me see
this how am I supposed to pay attention to
the credits and read everyone's name at the
same time thank you to America's number one
meal kid hellofresh for partnering with us
it's always great to partner with people who
Services you actually use because it's someone
like me who's always juggling a pack schedule
between filming and editing finding time for
healthy eating can be a challenge that's where
hellofresh has been a game changer for my life
with hellofresh I get farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and delicious recipes delivered right
to my doorsteps so I don't have to step outside
it's revolutionized my home cooking experience
making it not just easy but super enjoyable and
affordable keyw I recently tried their delicious
barbecue pineapple flatbreads and their zucchini
pomodora Panet bake both were mouth wateringly
delicious and fit perfectly with my pescatarian
lifestyle pescatarian M sounds fancy and asking
my friends who love meat hellofresh has an
incredible variety tempts me to be a meat
eater again people I know I've really recommended
their lemon parsley chicken parar I think is how
you pronounce it in the fuo chicken fajo tacos
regardless hellofresh menu has something for
everyone but of course it's not just about the
food it's about saving time too not having a wait
in line at a grocery store even self checkouts on
fast enough these days the convenience of having
everything delivered pre-portioned right to your
door is priceless especially with her quick and
easy meals like 15-minute recipes spending less
time in the kitchen and more time doing what I
love which is filming and editing so here's
the deal if you want a great way to support
the channel and also support you know having a
new lifestyle healthy affordable lifestyle in
the year 2024 go to hellofresh.com reject free
and use code reject free for free breakfast for
life you heard that right one breakfast item
per box while the subscription is active free
breakfast for life for hellofresh.com reject free
use promo code rejects free try it out and let me
know your favorite dishes stay healthy and let's
keep enjoying those movies and shows all right
reject Nation let's get real for a moment running
this channel is incredible but managing finances
especially taxes and budgeting both for the
channel and my personal life can be overwhelming
that's where rocket money has been a financial
Lifesaver for me even before I ever partnered
up with them like I said I've been very fortunate
to be working with Brands whose products I already
use so it's a win-win for and why but it can be
a win-win for you too cuz there's a reason I use
them rocket money is a personal finance app that
simplifies managing money by canceling unnecessary
subscriptions lowering bills and crafting a budget
that fits your specific lifestyle for someone
like me who can easily lose track of expenses to
throughout every single day of the month it's been
eye opening to see where I was overspending stuff
I don't use that I kept paying for especially
apps man I was way too many apps rocket money does
the heavy lifting by analyzing your spending then
customizes notifications to help you stay within
your budget goals it's not just about saving money
it's about actively seeing and feeling your
financial progress It's a great feeling they
track your monthly subscriptions too so many free
trials I signed up for that I forgot to you know
get rid of before the free trial was done making
it super easy to cancel the ones you don't use
couple of clicks and you're putting money back in
your pocket telling you have you ever found hidden
subscriptions or pay for services you forgot about
because rocket money is a huge asset in helping
to uncover those and even negotiate some of my
bills down to like 20% so if you're ready to take
control of your finances and there's no better
time than now because it is the beginning of the
year check out rocket money and see how much you
could be saving stop wasting money on things you
do not use so to help support the channel and help
support your wallet visit rocket money.com rejects
rocket money currently has over 5 million users
and has helped save its members an average of $720
a year over $500 million in canceled subscriptions
they've helped me and I'm confident they'll do the
same for you that's rocket money.com rejects your
bank account will thank you we just watched The
Man from Uncle if you're listening to us on Apple
and Spotify please go ahead rate this video uh and
yo okay so that would be great with Andrew and
myself we saw Wrath Of Me recap our guy Richie
movies Lock Stock snatch you saw Rock and roller
yes um have you seen Aladdin uh I saw the first
15 minutes well I saw ladin I enjoyed it uh I've
seen the Sherlock Holmes movies have you I've seen
the first one but I don't really remember it to be
honest I just remember the soundtrack Han Zimmer
okay so yeah I really don't remember it at all and
then we saw Wrath of man so there's a big gap here
of movies of guy Richie films that we haven't seen
so we saw Wrath of man really enjoyed it tonally
exact same thing as man for moncle oh exact super
goofy totally a Whimsical nature crazy production
design I almost thought I was watching the same
film I was like this guy does not have variety
this guy richy whatsoever all uh no very different
experience and I know this one came out uh first
was 2015 just a couple years after Man of Steel
and didn't really know anything about I heard
it was a spy movie but I I remembered seeing a
trailer but I couldn't tell you anything from
the trailer I recall and I I wanted to see just
because people had always recommended the movie as
like a fun spy Caper and I got to agree uh I had I
don't I think there's some some flaws in it that I
would like to you know dive into but I don't feel
like I spend too much time on it because what I
think is the intention of this film is that it
wants to you know have a panach style the zest
when it comes to the flavor of the you know spy
aesthetic the Spy genre films and the shows uh
from back then haven't seen Man from Uncle but it
seemed to me at least the impression I got is like
seems like that like because it's based on a show
is that uh sure the show I'm sure it's honoring
in a lot of ways but it seems to go further beyond
that and just honor a whole genre in it of itself
of a specific type of uh time period And I think
that you know guy Richie one of the things about
his movies is Guy Richie is often one of the
stars of his own movies you know what I mean
and I feel like that personality shines through
and through I'm reserving I'm I'm holding off on
talking about someone just so I can let you take
the lead on that and uh so yeah I feel like that
when it comes to this film like the editing again
is very solid in his use of knowing how to work
with his sound designer of when to go in and out
of sound with soundtracks like there's I feel like
he creates such a good sensory experience and I
feel like this era was really brought to life uh
in a way that felt like appropriately modern while
still hearkening back in a way that didn't feel
like it was I don't know um you know uh biting
off more than n could Chew in a way that seemed
like cheesy you know like I get what you're doing
it still felt like lived in but still felt modern
and period piece simultaneously I thought did a
really solid job at that with action scenes that I
was dazzled by like that that final one in the the
chase scene was uh brilliant in when they're going
through the island and getting you to understand
like the distance the scope and and make it like
this craziness but also being able to appreciate
when it was one take or or you could really feel
the stunt man behind it and the performers like
it wouldn't get lost in the edit I feel like
sometimes you know you watch like the behind the
scenes of certain action scenes and you're like
well it's hard to appreciate it when I see the
final product just because of how it's actually
assembled and cut together but here like yeah it's
crazy but I could keep up with it all and I'm able
to still it's like George Miller es and uh yeah
I I really thought that was great I have held
off onp talking about the man of the hour Henry
cell just for you I was going to say I thought
the best character by far was Uncle Rudy I love
how they went into his backstory we got to see
why he's such a tortur um no no I mean yeah Henry
Cav I mean he just the swaave the charm I mean the
energy he's just uh he's just so much fun to watch
you can tell too he's having a great time while
he's doing this too and I mean I just I know we
said it a couple times but just watching this I'm
like I really would love to watch him we could put
it close closer we're not reacting put it closer
that we could hear you clearer yeah there you go
I I really would love look that she the volume
difference you can hear yeah I I really would love
to see Henry caval as James Bond one day I mean I
think you said it best too like he could Encompass
you know both that Sean Conor and Daniel Craig
thing but um also too I really loved the chemistry
he had the three of them was really great but
especially him and Army Hammer and the way they're
able to build I mean because it it kind of yeah it
was a spy film but also like turned in turned into
a buddy I thought you were flexing turned into
like a little bit of a buddy cop type film too
and you know they completely are you know totally
different signs sides of the same coin type of
thing but you know they come to an understanding
and they uh I just I appreciated the the contrast
they are completely opposites of each other and
you know the way they you know build a rapport
with each other I just I loved their chemistry
and their interactions were so good and you know
by the end of the film like you could see that
they have a full understanding of each other and
I really even though it was kind of telegraphed
and predictable a little bit in terms of the the
watch thing it didn't bother me in any way uh I
thought that was a beautiful moment in the film
and Army Hammer just I know we had all the jokes
through the reaction with uh you know what's going
on and what happened in his personal life but uh
I actually did like his performance in it um and
I just again so polar opposite which I think was
necessary with this because you know there was a
certain uh level of charm that Henry caval I think
it was appropriate to do the exact opposite with
army hamur um and I think that's what works well
I mean it's kind of like the Lethal Weapon effect
like Rigs and merar are so different and that's
what why they're so perfect with each other and I
felt the same way while watching this and um yeah
and like you said too the sound design so freaking
good in this movie I mean even at the beginning
right away just starting us off with the silencer
sound I mean I I mean I just feeling that right
away and also to the um I love the camera work as
well in this too you had those reveal shots where
um starting off in the mechanic shop where they're
down below and then uh when he was opening the
safe this KY Richie has such a a specific style
and I just you can always feel like he's like you
said he's his own character uh in his own films
and I just so appreciate that but well let's the
audience play be a character with with with his
at least maybe he's always done that since snatch
and long stock maybe I just a notice back then
even though I love those movies um but especially
watching Wrath of man and this like he he chooses
his moment he knows how to play with perspective
a lot especially a movie such as this where
you deal with perspective and time and you go
backwards a little bit so that way you could see
what really went down or or how certain reveals
are are happening and you got many different
perspectives here and sometimes he just gives
you the audience perspective in a very literal
sense where you get moments such as the windows
are shut you can't hear what they're saying even
though you're following the characters with their
subtitles happening and the window goes down some
you could hear them and then knowing when to uh
have only music playing and then want to snap the
audience back into it in the same shot where they
bring the music back a lot of directors will rely
on like do a punch in here do a zoom do a cut and
he doesn't do that he'll just rely on the sound
whilst being in the exact same shot or the exact
same moving shot which I think is uh very unique
to guy Richie and back to an earlier point that
you were making about the two of them together it
is a very interesting contrast because there's a
buddy cop or buddy Spy you know it's usually
um It's usually the way they usually do that
is one's the straight man and one's like a little
bit of a wild character a little goofier you know
that's the generic way of doing it and like I said
don't know the show so I don't know you know how
accurate they are to the characters in the show
it's based on a show right I believe that's true
right um but what I really liked about is they did
such a good job at individually establishing Henry
caval individually establishing Army Hammer and
they're very unique to themselves and they didn't
sacrifice who they were in this for the sake of
writing like comedy back and forth between them or
writing banter between them like it's a different
kind of dynamic than I'm used to when associating
it with the genre like not one's not goofier
necessarily stupider or something like that you
know they they they each have their own skill set
and the respect level they earned for each other
felt like organic and genuine and none of it ever
like you always knew it was going to go that way
just cuz it's a movie but so you knew it would go
there but how they got there was actually done in
a in a way that was a little bit more subtle and
a movie that is also quite Lively and large that
that I really appreciated how they did it because
you know Army Hammer's Russian spy character is
uh the more emotional one and one with a lot of
pain and they have these this uh this touch where
whenever he's getting enrage like this dramatic
operatic music like overrides his system and and
you could feel like the the the pain the pathos
within this guy whereas Henry cavell's a little
bit more of like your traditional American spy
guy but with a uh you know with there's still
that heart underneath it it's still a Darkness
underneath him but not so much the extent of army
hammers but they my point is that when they have
them interact with each other they stay true to
the characters and they don't just go let's make
it a funny movie now let's make it a a thing like
they still feel like oh they're very they're very
fleshed out um for this world that they're in and
and I and yeah man I can't praise Henry caval
enough in this film he was he really I I heard
he was good mhm and but I didn't know he was going
to be like this this entertaining like he really
cuz here's the thing as as good as Army Hammer I
thought was like my personal point of VI I thought
he was really I thought he was actually really
good in the movie I think Alicia viander does
a really good job too the truth be told in when
Henry caval is not there you're thinking about it
it's it's just not as entertaining because you can
cut to Henry caval not with army like the movies
at its best when all of them are together um or
or at least Henry caval and Army Hammer however
you can cut to Henry caval being on his own not
with the other two leads and the movie is just
as entertaining in those moments like it's it's
a testament to the strength of him as a performer
in this film and to me it's [__] like this
that makes you go man you really lost something
there with Superman you lost something there with
Witcher you really lost uh like a great performer
on your hands because I'm used to Henry caval
being more like the serious brooding type like
there's a sense of humor that comes through with
him as geralt and The Witcher definitely not to
this extent he's still like for the most part
like a serious brooding character and here he's
not serious brooding guy right um yeah but yet
he's like very believable still I like he really
is to me I'm like this is a star performance yeah
even in the the mechanic shop and like when he was
in the car and like just hearing him just how
Jo how again the humor it's like you even said
it you're like this is like the traditional Clark
Kent that we would normally like clar it's like a
Superman and bond you either one man exactly
um you know and speaking about Army Hammer's
character I actually really liked the emotional
Arc we went through with the character you know
again feeling his pain throughout uh you know what
happened with his father and his mother and then
again seeing those scenes of Rage with him uh
I actually liked that I thought that was really
organically done and then by the end again very
well earned I also thought this film did a good
job too I I it's again a stylistic thing that guy
Richie does and it again very well earned in terms
of he'll say a couple L it's like a subversion
type of thing where he'll say some lines you hear
that lines of dialogue and then it's revealed
later on either a couple minutes later or 10 15
minutes later where it's like oh this is the rest
of the scene and it's like I just I love when he
does that stuff it's it's just very intelligently
done and then when it's and but he insert it like
it's edited properly and when he inserts it it's
like oh okay now I see cuz we didn't even know
what the plan was when they were going at the end
there uh when they were trying with tracking the
the uh when they were trying to get uh what's her
name Elizabeth Deli decki um when we were a little
confused and then when the plan was being revealed
like ah okay because when they were fully you know
shelling out like exactly what was happening
I just thought he did a he did that a couple
times throughout the film but he's he did that I
believe in Wrath of man and I'm sure snatch and
some of the other films that I can't remember the
scenes but he has a way of doing that I love when
he does it and it's such a stylistic choice of
his and I just so appreciate those I mean it's
not very well a lot of directors and editors
just don't go that route because if you mess
that up it can really screw up the scenes badly so
but he really does it well and he executes it in
a way that's methodical and just well really well
done you know in in a lot of ways I feel like guy
Richie and Christopher Nolan are kind of cut from
the same cloth like they're like they're British
they're British and they they love to play with
time and uh they have a unique voice unto their
own with their like they're very the emotions
you're left with for from their films are very
different I would say but there are things about
them that I find uh to be uh to be quite similar
it's just what you know you associate Nolan more
with The Prestige of it all right not not just his
movie I'm talking about like him as a was an art
director and you associate more guy Richie as like
just entertainment you know but but I think there
really is a a methodical attention and detail and
care that is truly lace throughout and and I I
don't know when it happened where guy rich just
started getting like kind of not the greatest not
hailed as like this truly great because I think
he is like a fantastic director sometimes I think
in the first 45 minutes of this movie I felt like
okay the first 20 20 minutes 20 or so minutes was
like really solid and then it does get to a point
where it gets a little down I I felt with some
of the more like you kind of siphon off you know
our three leads from each other or you just have
Army Hammer and elucha viander and you're you're
cutting around to like a lot of exposition about
Mission stuff that ultimately I was starting to
think like okay some of these scenes that aren't
um that aren't like action or or just meant to be
fun is actually kind of messing with the pacing of
the film and it's not as intriguing or interesting
it just wasn't and so I was I was like okay well
like the re cuz started having the thought of
like the it's not the mission that makes the
movie entertaining it's it's the it's it's the
uh actors together that make that are making
the movie entertaining and it was around the
time when the mission when everything started to
actually coales and come together in a way where
the mission at hand itself was interesting
where there was actual Stakes involved was
after Army Hammer and Henry caval do that Breakin
together and then then when the mission continues
okay now the mission is actually interesting but
it took a while to get there I felt I felt like
okay it's taken a while for that stuff to I know
you got to do the setup and everything and I just
sort of feel like the only parts of this movie
that I thought were a little bit um uh I don't
want to say tedious because tedious is too harsh
of a word just not as engaging and and it felt
like it was losing some of its flare and and and
pacing was was in that first like first half of
act two I would say yeah but once we reached that
midpoint with them it was like okay this movie is
like firing on all cylinders for me doesn't take
its foot off the pedal yeah there was that like
like you said that 15 20 minute stretch there but
after that yeah it was just but it was also worth
it because you needed all that information
for later I just think maybe the immediate
execution of it could have been a little sharper
in the way it was done to make it all thoroughly
entertained because you always had great actors
in you're like Jarry Harris I think is having an
having a ball of a time he's really fun yeah uh
the voices everyone's doing Hugh Grant another
great Edition Elizabeth dicki surprised me as wow
when she's here in the last half of the film she
is really intimidating she's intimidating she's
a scary presence a lot of times um a role like
that might be given to like a guy uh to making it
more of a male character and it just feels like
a cliche portrayal and she brought something very
different to it that I thought really elevated and
she is an interesting character too cuz you can
tell how piss she was after Henry kill was going
on about how he killed her husband and it's like
and also at the same time she slept with Henry Kev
which like again he's a very sve good-looking man
and all but it's like interesting relationship I
guess when you're that powerful and that ruthless
you just sleep around with whoever you want but uh
you know what I think it is with Nolan and Richie
is is that Nolan usually tells like a unique story
still and I feel like guy Richie takes at least
from just these two films he takes stories that
are a little more predictable and and and kind
of go by tropes and genre tropes of it but then
he executes them in a very unique way yeah that's
where I think his specialty is like when you're
getting the backstory with the with the husband
torture he's slipping through the SC the book and
I'm like that's a really unique way to instead
of like cutting to the footage you just see
photographs telling the tale yeah with like Uncle
Rudy I thought that was such a brilliant way of
telling the uh the back his backstory even though
that's a character like that that we don't really
give a [__] about but still an interesting
way to tell the backstory uh I and obviously
to the the ending there was clearly set up for
a sequel so as Warrior uh we're filming this we
don't know why there is no sequel I'm assuming
box office um because I feel like I mean got a
7.2 on IMDb so I got to assume let's look up some
stuff then my friend okay the TV series ran for
four years got you for like I Gotta Get You Out
of Here Andrew I know stop yelling at me I'll get
you out of here just wait we just want to find
the facts the facts on MBA where are the facts
on imba do you see them a little lower know where
they're located I do right there oh my God genius
genius oh no [__] you called that actually you
called that you said he he performed that cuz at
first they didn't show it I was like oh I couldn't
pull it off and then they showed they showed the
white shot you're like yep he performed that
holy [__] that was wild they often perform
their own stunts I'm in with Henry caval I
yeah he's going to do that hammer was more
enthusiastic about his stunts to the point the
stunt double joke that he hardly had a chance to
do anything yeah yeah I mean I that's what I mean
by those action scenes you you can actually tell
oh that is them doing that yeah I do remember
you calling that out too like when uh we were
on one of the chase sequence is like holy [__]
that's Henry K driving right there kav admit he
was relieved to not have a shirtless scene in
this movie after stringing a movies where had
to be in top shape uh he was glad to focus on
his performance for once and not his physique
crazy cuz he looks great sure yeah yeah I'm
sure he was looking at the script where the
shirtless scene okay I'm signing in for signing
up for this movie no sure David Beckham what Army
Hammer was the only one who watched the M from
Uncle show from uh for his role he was the only
member to do so that's funny oh is partially
developed by Ian Fleming oh so the bond touch
is very real you could feel it aoleon solo has
started as a character and the in the novel of
Goldfinger oh interesting cool uh okay the
tunnel say that's cool all right yeah yeah
I'm briefly some of these are not interesting
yes sure why not there was the projectionist at
the beginning of the movie that was David Beckham
I guess so why did I not recognize that damn it
okay that tells us nothing about why there's no
sequel hold on a second hold on box office Maybe
okay is reportedly in the
works oh can you recap oh
my God how funny January 5th 2024 just this month
oh that's kind of funny how that was like as we're
doing as we're doing just just so recent uh there
is movement on it okay okay the disappointing
box offers turns they got mixed reviews that
surprises me so it's gained a following thanks
to the streaming okay yeah that sucks about the
box office this this deserve better whatever
but the problem has come in the form of like
Army Hammer obviously yeah it's going to be a
public relations uh you're going to have some
problems there I mean here's the thing I think
Army Hammer's really great in the movie I do he's
great he's great but but I could the only thing
that would really be like I'm not going to watch
it if of course totally yeah yeah I mean yeah
would depend on who they get I mean I guess I
could see that but yeah totally what you said
if they re if they didn't have Henry Cavo I'm
not interested well I had a blast with this one
Andrew um I hope you guys had fun with it too do
you want the Man from Uncle sequel will you still
watch it even Army Hammer's not in it leave your
thoughts down below be sure to subscribe leave a
like um I don't know which guy Rich probably the
gentleman I would love to see the gentleman I've
heard such good things about that movie and I've
never seen the trailer I don't know anything about
it so I'm like all right if people are hyping the
[__] up out of that movie got to keep that guy
Richie experience going all right talk to you guys
soon David Gandy my man I don't know what more
there is to say to you David except we haven't
heard from you in a while I know are you okay
did you get kidnapped it's going down a very
different path I was more like guess you don't
give a [__] about us anymore you [__] yeah
have you become a jerk that's the worst fate
of all your subconscious instincts are very
different than mine not you go are you okay are
you concerned I go wow guy must be a dick what an
ass what a real jerk this guy must be to neglect
us who have done so much for your life yeah we've
definitely done more for you than you've ever
name one thing you've done for us out of the
selflessness and kindness of your own heart David
you didn't drive down forever just to see us live
one day you haven't given us countless gifts and
money on top like dined with us you know broken
bread with us literally and figuratively we have
slightly entertained you and helped you pass some
time what greater gift is that what greater
gift than distraction but buddy I don't know
where you've been I don't know why we haven't
heard from you I know we've been a lot busier
since then I feel like since the patreon's gotten
bigger and the Channel's g bigger some of our ogs
like yourself just don't really like to chime in
with us as much anymore which I'm very grateful
for because I don't got the time to talk to you
anymore time to engage with to really focus on
your needs but dude you've been an absolute
blessing in our lives and I I miss you man
and if you're ever down here in our neck of the
woods again because Lord knows I'm never make
it at to Arizona what the hell's there to do
stare at at Cactus boring as [__] try stop
the election what David's out there doing right
now he's photographing just Cactus after Cactus
Bing [__] standing in that disgusting heat God
your life must be miserable now yeah David what
are you doing hell happens in Arizona are you
someone here listening from Arizona hate your
life have at least a couple of arizonians it
can't just be David Al David favorite on record
favorite Arizona right now David's just standing
next to his AC looking at us on his phone yeah
how boring and responding to a video that won't
respond back in real time yeah stop man stop It
Anyway keep you in our prayers to the same God
we definitely believe in yeah and I hope that uh
I hope that everything's all right in your neck
of the woods yeah keep on playing Tunes I think
of you every time I hear a guitar or when I see a
cactus or when I see a cactus around here happens
more than you think my my flashback timeline
plays in linear order of the times we've met
and talk like a movie dve oh yeah I see a cactus
and I go right back to the first [Laughter] memory
a clip metal stuck in time anyway miss
you buddy hope you're doing [Music] well